Hi, everyone. In this lesson,
we're going to talk about the introduction to Lumen,
and how to work with the properties and settings,
and get the proper workflows in
the right direction when using the tool.
So let's get started.
First up, you're probably wondering, what is Lumen?
John's talked about it a lot,
and what does it exactly mean?
Well, Lumen is Unreal 5's fully dynamic global illumination,
like we mentioned before,
reflection system that is designed for next-generation consoles,
default global illumination, and reflection system.
So it's not dependent on having the latest machine,
but higher settings using ray tracing support,
which we'll talk about how to turn that on,
are GPU expensive.
So a new machine in that case may be needed.
So just keep that in mind.
If you want the full capability of Lumen,
you might want to make sure you have
the latest hardware that's able to
run things accordingly using ray tracing.
So Lumen renders diffuse
interflexion with infinite bounces,
which we talked about, and indirect specular reflections
in large detailed environments.
At scales ranging from millimeters to kilometers,
and again, we've mentioned this before,
and where it really shines,
it's able to be able to handle a large scene using Nanite,
and in times you may want to even experiment with megalites,
but it's able to get the bounces that you need,
the reflected surfaces that you need.
Everything seems to come together really
nicely and smoothly without a huge hit on your performance.
Now, like anything, you can throw the kitchen sink at it
and put a lot of stuff in your scene,
and if they're not optimized properly,
there can be some issues, but Unreal right now,
as it stands, can handle a lot of geometry,
a lot of lights, and a lot of reflective surfaces.
So you just have to manage accordingly,
and it's always a good reference to be able to prioritize
what is the most important, what the player will see,
and what the camera will see if you're working
with linear content such as film.
Those things will get the better amount of work
and amount of love, so that's still a good,
even though Unreal can do some great things,
it's still a good practice.
So Lumen GI, diffuse indirect lighting.
So a light bounces and color bleeds.
It handles both of those like a champ.
It allows things to bounce off,
and you'll see my little graphic here on the side.
As the camera picks up, the light bouncing from surfaces
and from lights and so forth,
it actually does refraction really well
and handles it really, really great,
as well as glowing objects,
which we'll talk about in just a bit.
It provides infinite diffuse bounces.
Unreal Engine 5's Nanite-visualized geometry
allows geometry to be much more detailed.
So not only do we have the pairing of Lumen,
which is optimized to be able to handle a large scene,
and with MegaLights, a good amount of lights,
you also can pair it up with Nanite,
and I recommend you do,
because Nanite, Virtual Shadow Maps, and Lumen
are like the three musketeers.
They work really well together.
So Lumen achieves full resolution shading
while computing indirect lighting cheaper than before.
So it gets better and better
with each iteration and noise gets removed.
There may be a tiny bit of noise,
but you'll notice there's a dramatic amount less of noise
in 5.5 versus some of the earlier 5.3 and four releases.
We also have Skylighting is solved
as part of Lumen's final gather process
and includes a sky shadowing.
And that allows indoor spaces to be much darker
than outdoor lighting, much more natural effect.
So Lumen also provides lower quality global illumination
for lit translucency and volumetric fog.
So it handles it like a champ.
So again, a missive you gotta be careful with,
so let's talk a little bit about that for a second.
And we'll do a little bit of demo
and see what it looks like in engine.
So missive materials propagate light
through Lumen's final gather
with no additional performance costs.
And it does it quite well.
And this will show up on your characters
as well as your environment pieces.
But however, there's a limit to how small
and bright and missive areas can be,
but before they can begin to cause noise,
artifacts to appear.
Now, keep in mind when this is improved though,
but still if you have a very small glowing object,
you could get noise
because it's harder to solve them manually.
I mean, it's harder to solve those small ones
compared to like if you just put an actual light
in the scene is really what I mean here.
So you just gotta keep these things in mind.
You have to consider, you know,
if you have a very small glowing object
that needs to glow,
you might wanna do a combination
where you have just a minimal glow
going off that material,
but then you're also putting in a physical light
to make things a little bit more controllable.
So it's kind of give or take.
So just test it out and you'll notice
it has improved greatly from other versions,
but it does a great job as it stands.
So Lumen, what is it?
Lumen solves indirect specular or reflections
for full range of material roughness values.
Diffuse GI and shadowed skylight
can be seen in all reflections
and Lumen reflections also support clear coat materials.
So you'll see that it actually works really well
for such things as car materials.
What it replaces.
So what it replaces is skylight
with AO or unshadowed objects.
We have screen space GI
and also replaces ray tracing GI
and third-party GI solutions
such as Nvidia's ray tracing XGI.
So since 5.5 Lumen can now run at 60 Hertz
on platforms for which there is hardware support,
thanks to many improvements to the system
that the underpin hardware ray tracing,
you'll see that there a little acronym
and you'll see this a couple of times,
the hardware ray tracing.
These improvements also impact the performance
and capabilities of path tracer and light baking.
So it's kind of a domino effect.
We've improved it,
but it also is made it so that it also improves
path tracer, which is really fantastic.
So how to set it up.
In the next video,
we're gonna go into some detail
on how to set up these in your system
and things to look out for and caveats.
And we're going to set it up in our scene
and I'll point out all the things you need to consider.
Thanks again.